ADHD stands for attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder it's a very big
problem the current estimates are that
11% of children more than one out of ten
meet the diagnosis for ADHD and there's
been a remarkable growth in the number
of adults who meet the diagnostic
criteria the literature is that about
half of children no longer meet the
diagnosis by the time they're adults
often there are remaining difficulties
so they don't outgrow it as if they
never had it but often they have
considerable improvement that shows up
in their educational and occupational
success in this study we're interested
in investigating the default mode
Network and patients who had ADHD the
default mode network are regions that
have been known to be typically
activated more during race and those
religions are the medial prefrontal
cortex the posterior cingulate lateral
final cortices the default network is
the first time we can have a neural
system that reflects self-referential
processing what's been found in
typically developing people is we have
the synchrony and your default mode
network so when these regions go up the
other regions go up in ADHD that's not
the case and that's been identified in
adults that's been identified in
children but it hasn't been identified
is people that have been diagnosed as
children and then followed
longitudinally and that's what's unique
about our sample
so these subjects came in we got
structural scans diffusion-weighted
scans and one of the scans we got was
this resting state scanner so during
that scan their job was just to lie as
still as possible for six minutes and
think of nothing in particular so in the
room inner group the question was would
their brain look like that people that
resisted with their ADHD diagnosis and
in adulthood or look like controlled and
what they looked like was like controls
like people that had never been
diagnosed with a
in other words it looks like the
remitted ADHD somehow we're able to
normalize our resting state functional
connectivity to the PCC and attract the
current clinical status it wasn't that
the people that remitted were completely
like controls in every way possible we
also know at rest that there are these
task-related networks these tests
positive networks and we wanted to see
the relationship between the test
positive networks and the default mode
network in our example so in control
they show an anti correlation so when
the default low network goes up the test
positive network goes down and so what
we wanted to identify was whether or not
there is a similar kind of anti
correlation in the room iterative and
persistent group and what we found was
this was not observed in the readers or
in the persisting in other words that
wasn't emitted and significantly less
default mode Network anti correlations
and regions like the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex
donessa jessa the developmental history
of having ADHD does leave something
impact that we can see in the brain and
so so it's a little of both it's both
some religions clinically but also some
continuation from the chocolate history
first of all it communicates that some
significant number of individuals do
improve in terms of clinical status the
second thing is we hope that the
convergence of different forms of
evidence will help make people more
confident about the diagnosis and
treatment selection so this is a small
step forward but we're hoping that
convergence objective scientific
information will start to help make it
easier to see what was
you know correct useful pathway to help
a child